so it's like of course I'm his wife but
I'm also a thing you know and we're not
the kind of people that's like all since
i'm mattre tu meri to me we gotta be on
each other's every single song you know
we wait into a record made sense and so
it was something that we both feel like
okay this is the one and that's what I
loved when you first got together
did you ever plan to say like okay one
day we're gonna work together when it
comes to the music
no we first up together I knew he was
rapping I always loved his stuff we
actually wake up love is not the first
song that we have together like we have
other songs together like it's not
anything that's like forced or I didn't
feel like I was forced to put him on my
album I don't feel like you know I'm
forced him to put me on his stuff you
know I'm saying like he kind of just
like a big chunk hop on his track right
quick yeah this is the one I like this
right here me no exam or if you subtract
that maybe I might play that he not
feeling on track that heat my favorite
I'm not feeling I just love the fact
that we really move as best friends and
we do what's right so that feature
coming was definitely bound to happen
you know and it was the perfect song for
him to be on I want to talk about your
features because a girl girl Erykah Badu
Lauryn Hill Missy Elliott I know that
throughout your career you've dealt with
you know just a lot of people under
estimating you but for some reasons not
for some reason I know why I think we
all know why the greats have always
acknowledged you you know Tiana LT out
it's over
baby I love her for month I remember
Elton John on that videos Elton John
hitting you up and saying like you're
yes let's dope how does it feel to be
recognized by your idols and these icons
I mean that feels great you know my mom
used to always tell me when I used to
like let trivial things get to me well
there was common so an ad say there's
different things like that and she'll
always be right all that matters
the right people right the right people
know what's up the right people love you
I never really understood what she meant
by that and so I started to realize that
the people that I looked up to the
people that I respect you so much knew
exactly who I was respected my work and
I'm like wow you know so when it came
time to act with these features and
different things like that it really
worked in my favor because I stayed on
the path of you know reminding myself to
stay focus on what the real goal is you
know and appreciating the people that
appreciate you you know and appreciating
the fact that the right people are
watching no matter what you think no
matter what you see no matter what you
hear the right people watching you never
know who's watching so it's like to be
able to work on this album and to reach
out to people and get a yes immediately
really show that my hard work has not
been going unnoticed and that the right
people were watching and the right
people were paying attention I think
your story of resilience is so inspiring
and the fact that you can you're a woman
of faith you know it has definitely
helped throughout this process because
when I think about it I'm just like even
personally as somebody that's aspiring
to be something in my career we always
look at people outside of ourselves to
you know measure where we are but
there's never been a Teyana Taylor you
know so you can't look outside yourself
or there's not you know there's never
that you knew in this um saying like
being who you are and I think that it's
so good that you understand that and you
keep pushing forward cuz I mean that
helps me that helps everybody to
watching you conquer this thing you know
thank you thank you and I really
appreciate that
seriously yeah yeah I mean it for sure
stuff up is the best love uh when you go
take that wristband Oh
tea party bit over don't need make-up to
dress you I love your production company
the aunties which is a group of talented
women creating adult continual can you
talk a little bit about the women behind
the team and how you all come up with
these concepts because your videos are
literally breathtaking thank you
I mean honestly like I know a lot go
when they hear that I have a production
company or I'm a director I know some
people feel like you know oh she
probably stole her name on stuff or she
doesn't know I'm very very hands-on me
and my partner's Coco is a producer with
the aunties but also you know co-founder
she's just so amazing because he really
sit and it's really just the two of us
but when we hire people for jobs a lot
of females men as well like we don't
discriminate but the fact that there's
really two girls that's running this you
know black own production company is
important for me you know so we really
just sit back and create this stuff from
scratch so we literally do everything
in-house ourselves just me and Coco so
she's kind of like the typewriter and
I'm thinking of like all the ideas like
okay we should do this Center that is I
now make that ass obnoxious you know
create a treatment you know so we're
creating the treatments we're writing
the story we're we're writing everything
out you know we're on Google creating
our mood boards you know I'm saying like
looking at different pictures getting
different types of inspiration like this
is like with very very hands-on we don't
really have like we're not just
forwarding stuff to people or interns
for them to do all the work we legit do
everything and then on the day we we
hire everybody to come in and all play
their part but at that point it's just
two black girls making it happen you
know she's producing I'm directing and
you know we making that happen
[Music]
I've been here and so many people talk
about how amazing it's been to see you
evolve from this dull 16 year old looks
pissed off about her skateboard ramp on
sweet 16 to this beautiful woman and
wife and mother and artist how does your
new album the album reflects who you are
as a woman today oh I think it
definitely reflects Who I am as a woman
today because there's all the part of
growth you know we all find ourselves as
women and I think also being a mom and a
wife is so much that you learn it's just
so much that you go through and I think
with this album I kind of wanted to have
a lot of fun as far as the subject on
the on the records but also kind of go
through all women go through I didn't
want people to feel like because I'm
married that that means that it was
going to be happily married music for 23
songs you know cuz at the end of the day
whether you happily married marry or
whatever it is is like we've all still
been through something before we all
have experienced heartbreak you all have
experienced the trials and tribulations
of just growing up and finding yourself
as a woman you know so I think my albums
have been major steps of growth for me I
love it was broken out in subsections
can you explain that really quick for
everywhere no I listened to a lot of
guided meditation so sometimes you'll
have a meditation and they can be in
like literally eight to ten minutes and
you'll have a section that's that speaks
all in love and you have another section
that speaks on you know gratitude and
another one that speaks on you relaxing
and nothing that's just like bedtime you
know we're healing it's so many
different sections of a guided
meditation is not for you to listen to
all of them in one day it's really
beautiful whatever mood you're in
wherever you're feeling to get into that
bag and reset yourself calm yourself and
that played a big part on you know
sectioning off my army because I feel
like it's like a guided meditation
whether it's good bad love
funny trying whatever it is embodies
with every devotion orator
[Music]